انا بفكره انه انا مبسوطه ماني مبسوطه وقت
اللي ما ببيع بجوع وماعم اكل مجبوره اطلع
ابيع كرمل ساعد اهلي انا معي عمري ع سنوات
بعد ما انصرف من المدرسه بطلع ببيع رينجز
كرمل جيب خبز لاهلي بيع ب 30 ليره يعني
دولار لما برجع من المدرسه بنزل مطر وبرد
كثير بتعرف يا عمو انه بيطلع اخوي من
الساعه 10 كرمال ه هول الرقتين والوحده
بخمس ورقات كمان بيطلع ما بيرجع للساعه ثه
مطر وبرد وحل وبيجي معبي حاله وحل هذا
بيشتري وهذا ما بيشتري كمان بيقولوا لي شي
بخمسه شي ب ليرتين لما حدا بيجي بيكسر لي
خاطري وما بيشتري مني بينكسر قلبي يا عمو
انا امبارح زعلت كثير ما بعت البق الدبل
ودخلتهم على البيت انقهر كثير لما بشوف
ابوي هيك ما معما صار يجيب لنا خبز ابوي
بيقول لي انا خوفان عليك ما تلطش ك سياره
بقول له يا بابا انا بدير بالي على حالي
امي بتزعل علي كثير وبنكس قلب علي بتقول
لي انت ما شغلتك بقول لي يا ماما انه انا
مجبوره ب يعني بكون برد كثير ومطر اصعب
الشيء عندي بتعرف يا عم عم بحكي معك انا
بردان كثير لما برجع من المدرسه بشوف اهلي
باركين جنب
الصوبيا وبكوني انا بردانه كثير بس مجبوره
انزل بها ان شاء الله الله بده يفرج علينا
وعلى كل البنات مثلك يا عم هذا قدر
الله بالكيت بالله بده يصير اتمنى انه
تفرج علينا وتفرج على كل هالعالم
وانه نرجع من المدرسه نلعب بالعاب
ونفرح
ه